[Music]
one of the key themes of philip k dick's
novel to android's dream of electric
sheep
is the technology that human beings have
developed and how they incorporate it
into their lives and what effects it
actually has
on them
as people and technology can be good in
some respects and bad in other respects
we find this to be the case with the
very first bit of technology that is
introduced in the first paragraphs of
chapter one
of the work so the very first sentence
runs like this a merry little surge of
electricity piped by automatic alarm
from the mood organ beside his bed
awakened rick deckard surprised it
always surprised him to find himself
awake without prior notice he rose from
the bed stood up in his multi-colored
pajamas and stretched
now in her bed his wife erin opened her
gray unmary eyes blinked then groaned
and shut her eyes again
you set your penfield too weak he said
to her i'll reset it and you'll be awake
and
keep your hand off my settings her voice
held bitter sharpness i don't want to be
awake
he seated himself beside her bent over
her and explained softly if you set the
surge up high enough you'll be glad
you're awake that's the whole point at
setting c it overcomes the threshold
barring consciousness as it does for me
friendly because he felt well disposed
towards the world his setting at bennett
d he patted his bit her bare pale
shoulder and then she says get your
crude cop's hand away
now
two people in very different moods on
waking up but it's in some respect
because of what's going on with this
mood organ where you can
dial up various affectivities moods
feelings desires
and
this is a piece of technology that goes
straight to the human brain
and human beings are not merely you
could say
victims of it or
passive patience of it they get to
decide what they're going to do in terms
of
dialing these moods there's actually a
catalog as we find much later on that
erin is looking through trying to
determine what kind of mood she should
set things at and there's basically two
kinds of things there's the mood itself
and then there's the
the gain or the amount that you can set
it for so deckard sets his to wake up in
a good mood in the morning
and erin apparently doesn't set it high
enough and wakes up in her usual kind of
despondent and depressed
mood and so then there's a whole
conversation after this but the key
thing here to to get across is
this apparatus the penfield mood
organ taps directly into
the human brain
and allows certain aff activities to be
reliably reliably produced
and at particular levels so it's a way
you could say for a human being
to decide
their own
mood through the use of
this apparatus is this completely
new no i mean we can do this through
what we can call technologies of the
self or philosophical exercises or
spiritual practices so there's an entire
side of agency on that we can do it
through taking drugs you know if you
take antidepressants the idea is that
you're trying to put yourself into not
necessarily a single mood but at least a
better mood overall and we could go on
and on and on
you know we could say that
music is used to put us into certain
moods particularly in relation to like
film and television
or commercials
and so there's lots of lots of ways that
human beings can already affect their
moods this just makes it more precise
and
predictable
so what are the different moods that are
available some of them have numbers some
of them are just mentioned
the first thing that
deckard considers dialing up is he's
getting into you know an argument uh
he's irritable and so you know his wife
is giving him a hard time for killing
androids which is his job
and he's here we go um
at his console he hesitated between
dialing for a thalamic suppressant which
would abolish his mood of rage or a
thalamic stimulant which would make him
irked enough to win the argument right
so he's
considering tinkering around with his
own
current mentality and then irian says
if you dial
for greater venom then i'll dial the
same i'll dial the maximum and you'll
see a fight that makes every argument
we've had up to now seem like nothing
dial and see just try me right so
there's an initial things you can you
can make yourself um less angry or you
can make yourself more angry right those
are possibilities to the level of
venom
what does rick die dial for himself
instead a
business-like professional attitude
which is probably kind of similar to one
of the other later moods that he has so
there's a range of moves that are good
for
you know common life the workplace and
that's what he dials up and then she
says something to him that's
quite striking um because he says i'm
scheduling myself
for uh you know particular moods
examining the schedule for january 3rd
1992 right he sees that this
professional attitude was it was called
for
and she says my schedule for today
lists a six-hour self-accusatory
depression
and rick says
why the hell did you dial that what
that's that's terrible i mean it's kind
of funny that it's even an option in the
mood oregon but she's like well i found
that it's actually quite quite helpful
for me why
so she says i was sitting here one
afternoon and um there was this you know
advertisement that came on for monty
bank led cod pieces so for a minute i
shut off the sound and i heard the
building the and then rick says empty
apartments and so this is something that
is affecting people's moods the
lack of
cohabitators you could say in the midst
of a big city
and so
she finds that
this is actually a useful mood for her
to to go into why she says at the moment
when i had the tv sound off i was in a
382 mood i had just dialed it i heard
the emptiness intellectually but i
didn't feel it my first reaction
consisted of being grateful we could
afford a penfield mood organ
then i realized how unhealthy it was
sensing the absence of life not just in
this building but everywhere
and not reacting so
sometimes the moods that you pick out
can conceal what should be your you call
it your existential attitude towards
things so she sets every so often a
self-accusatory
depression
and um she says uh i left the tv sound
off sat down on my mood organ and
experiments and i finally found a
setting for despair so i put it on my
schedule for twice a month i think
that's a reasonable amount of time to
feel hopeless about everything about
staying here on earth after everyone
who's smart has immigrated and then
rick points out that that could put you
into like a feedback loop though you're
apt to stay in it not dial your way out
despair
about total reality is self-perpetuating
and she says oh you know not a problem i
actually program an automatic resetting
for three hours later
481
awareness of the manifold possibilities
open to me in the future new hope that
and he says i i know 481 he uses that
combination himself
so this is something
that uh
is you might say a little bit of a
pallet cleanser or a reset
this openness to the manifold
possibilities
uh that are that are in front of you an
optimistic mood
and then we get to some other quite
interesting moods that you can set
one of which is actually
self-referential but before that we have
888
the desire to watch tv
no matter what is
on it so if you're really bored you can
just set that and then just zone out in
front of the tv i i kind of think that a
lot of people have that in their heads
already
with respect to streaming and music and
you know youtube and things along those
lines
three
is the
desire to dial a mood so if you find
yourself
unable to decide
or just kind of listless you can dial
that and then that feeds you back into
the interaction
with the
penfield now she says something very
interesting about that
she says i can't dial a setting that
stimulates my cerebral cortex into
wanting to dial if i don't want to dial
i don't want to dial that most of all
because then i will want to dial in
wanting to dial is right now the most
alien drive i can imagine i just want to
sit here on the bed and
stare at the floor so she wants she
wants out of this at least at some times
this
feedback loop and then um they you know
sort of reconcile and
she actually says
i i'll dial anything you want me to to
be ecstatic sexual bliss i'll feel i
feel so bad i'll even endure that what
the hell what difference does it make
and then rick says i'll dial for both of
us at her console he dialed 594 pleased
acknowledgement of husband's superior
wisdom in all matters so he's you know
um
in some respects treating her as as an
invalid or
somebody who's lower than him he's uh
using it to to get her to
view him as
a way she didn't just earlier as being
right and stuff like that and then he
dials himself
a creative and fresh attitude towards
his job which he's definitely gonna need
because he's kind of you know burnt out
on his job quite frankly and will get
more burnt out as things go on
now we encounter the penfield
unit
being discussed at you know some length
uh later on roy beatty one of the
androids actually the leader of the
androids who have escaped to earth and
are being hunted by um rick deckard
sets up a penfield
and he he's got it connected to
a tripwire so he says
this assembly has a penfield unit built
into it when the alarm has been
triggered it radiates a mood of panic
to the intruder
unless he acts very fast which he may
enormous panic i have the gain turn all
the way up no human being can remain in
the vicinity more than a matter of
seconds that's the nature of panic it
leads to random circus motions
purposeless flight and muscle and neural
spasms so this is a way for them to try
to
kill the
bounty hunter rick deckard
later on towards the very end
we have a very interesting set of
passages deckard has
finished you know the fights and and
killing of the androids he's he's gone
off he's
been involved with with mercer there's
all sorts of things going on he's out in
the desert he finds a toad
and picks it up and then drives back
uh
to to see his
wife
now
here's where the passage begins at the
penfield mood organ erin deckard sat
with her right index finger touching the
number dial but she did not dial
she felt too listless and ill to want
anything a burden which closed off the
futures and any possibilities which it
might once have
contained if rick were here she thought
he'd get me to dial three and that way
i'd find myself wanting to dial
something important ambulant joy or if
not that then possibly an 888 the desire
to watch tv no matter what's on it
and so she's you know sort of speak out
of the framework of the
mood organ she's in like an you know a
real depression not a just penfield mood
uh
stimulated depression and she's you know
she's unable to use this device to do
anything she views it as kind of hollow
but if if rick is there then
he can set things right
and she says
here we go
putting the knocks on it at the
apartment door putting down the penfield
manual she jumped up thinking i don't
need to dial now
i already have it if it is rick he'll
he'll take care of it and you know he
says hi and
she says it's nice to see you and then
he says i have something and he he's uh
got the box with the toadette and she
says i'll fix your coffee. all of this
is happening
without the stimulation of the
mood organ which plays such a
major role apparently
in their life but they're kind of
weaning themselves away from it by the
end of the novel
so this is a very interesting early
introduced piece of technology
that plays a significant role within the
book
doesn't get brought into the movie
adaptation the blade runner at all
for uh discussion or reference or
anything like that but
it's it's a major uh
theme you could say
within this work how much are we
responsible for how can we tinker with
our moods our
desires our
inclinations all these affective things
that make up our life
you